it doesn't look like much but when no
one can hear you this piece of metal at
the bottom of the sea it means the world
Paul Robson once traveled the globe an
international superstar performing to
sellout audiences across America and the
world filmed theater song or speech
Robson make people want to listen no
they can't the US State Department have
revoked his passport because his
powerful voice is radically off message
he talks of lynchings corporate greed of
segregation and in the 1950s at the
height of McCarthyism his left-wing
views are enough to have him branded
communist unamerican a threat to the
nation and they don't just bar him from
leaving the country they bar him from
performing in public anywhere but they
haven't counted on Robson's
unlikely ally a new technology that can
set him free the submarine repeater is
an amplifier for telephone cables it can
boost a feeding signal a millionfold
meaning phone signals and so phone lines
can go further can go anywhere it's a
solid worker tough enough to withstand
freezing cold and crushing pressure
tough enough to work on the ocean bed
now a string of these high-tech British
and American repeater spans the Atlantic
for the first time in history a phone
line connects the two countries and
Robson's British supporters have a
brainwave maybe now he can reach them
without leaving America in 1957 a crowd
of supporters parks into some Pancras
Town Hall in London to hear their hero
sing tonight the medium is truly the
message solidarity everyone waits on
tenterhooks and then
hello hello hello Paul can you hear me
yes I can Oh wonderful we're come over
all right oh I can't tell you that by
joining forces repeaters have given one
voice that power to cross an ocean the
quality is so high that some of the
audience think they're hearing a record
and the message is clear enough to be
held well beyond the town hall the
following year the US Supreme Court
declares it unconstitutional for oopsy's
passport to be barred he's free all with
a little help from his friends and the
Information Age giving us all the voice
[Music]
Oh